et pour en parler promettre kaki
présidente de l'association les oranges
nous a rejoints bonjour monsieur y
compris d'être sur notre plateau alors
tout d'abord quel est votre sentiment
par rapport à cette étude parue hier est
ce que vous êtes d'accord sur ce texte
sur justement les éléments déclencheurs
de cette contestation des régions où il
ya des éléments très intéressants
ceci dit c'est pas nouveau vous avez une
grande dame une historienne qui
s'appelle ludivine bantigny et qui a
travaillé justement sur ces combats des
gens de peu en province déjà et qui a
déjà montré que les luttes et les
combats n'étaient pas spécifiquement à
paris mais qu'il se passait aussi
ailleurs ça c'est le premier point est
le deuxième point en effet le
déclassement social c'est quoi c'est la
baisse d'une position sociale est
aujourd'hui ce qui a de très important
c'est que non seulement il y a une
position de déclassement de groupe donc
c'est une menace de groupes le général
mais aussi la peur du déclassement aussi
pour ses enfants
c'est à dire que le fait que les enfants
dont on investit beaucoup pour avoir un
diplôme pour qu' il puisse demain avoir
une situation je dirais enviable comme
tous les parents souhaitent
et bien aujourd'hui non plus cette
garantie là avec notamment la
concurrence violent de ce système
libéral qui précarisent l'ensemble des
gens aujourd'hui on est dans des
systèmes de contrat vous et moi
n'importe qui n'a plus la ne peut plus
avoir la sérénité de se dire voilà je me
projette sur quelques années c'est à
dire que du jour au lendemain il y à 7
avec l'avènement de ce système de de
concurrence d'une part mais aussi de de
mise en tension par rapport à cette
précarité
ce que robert castel appelait la
désaffiliation et donc l'avènement des
gilet jaune est le produit de tout ça
c'est à dire que à la fois en effet il
ya une absence totale de
de vie sociale c'est à dire d'ailleurs
pourquoi les gens sont partis dans la
périphérie là aujourd'hui c'est vrai que
cette étude se concentre sur ce
déclassement social qui est peut-être la
cause justement de ce qu'on a vu
aujourd'hui c'est fait un an et demi les
gilet jaune sont mobilisés dans la rue
et pourtant au départ c'était
l'augmentation du prix du carburant qui
qui a provoqué cette cette vraie colère
oui ça c'est la goutte mais qui est le
produit de la gentrification autour de
paris dire que petit à petit les gens de
milieux populaires ne pouvait plus
habités autour de paris et à paris
puisque c'est paris devenue un musée
aujourd'hui on peut plus y entrer comme
ça c'est quand même dix mille euros le
mètre carré à paris donc personne ne
peut plus habiter à paris et sa banlieue
proche
donc les gens vont de plus en plus loin
mais on peut on les a incités à aller de
plus en plus loin donc ils ont acheté un
petit pavillon disant bon voilà on va
voir le bonheur la paix etc
or il se trouve que il y à une
précarisation dans cet espace là c'est à
dire qu'avec l'augmentation des
transports l'impossibilité de circuler
et donc où le fait que ça impacte
énormément sur leur budget est bien
celle asphyxie générale
plus vous ajoutez à ça et dont l'étude
ça a été montré aussi la baisse de la
vie associative la baisse des services
publics
le fait que par exemple aujourd'hui ce
gouvernement mais qui n'est pas
seulement le fait de ce gouvernement il
faut rappeler sa fête dure depuis trente
ans en fait mais qu'il ya une
accélération à partir de monsieur
sarkozy avec monsieur hollande est donc
monsieur bacon à continuer à amplifier
cette chose là mais avec une chose très
importante que les gilets jaunes ont
bien capté qui est l'humiliation et le
mépris et ça si vous voulez aujourd'hui
à une situation de décomplexer quand on
va dans une usine de femmes et qu'on ne
peut se permettre de dire abbas et des
illettrés et bien effectivement il ya un
ressentiment encore plus large
et donc vous avez une agrégation des
gens et aujourd'hui ce qui est
intéressant il ya quelque chose de
nouveau
depuis quelques jours c'est justement de
cette convergence des luttes
je suis allé hier à la manifestation du
mouvement social et j'ai rencontré des
gilet jaune des professeurs des gens de
toutes conditions sociales et qui
convergent qui disent c'est plus
possible à la il me reste vraiment très
très peu de temps on voit que les gilets
jaunes ça fait un an et demi qu'ils
luttent aujourd'hui dans la rue le
gouvernement n'a pas fait vraiment de
pas vers eux aujourd'hui il ya cette
mobilisation contre la réforme des
retraites ça fait maintenant six
semaines
est-ce que vous pensez que ce genre de
mute ce genre de mobilisation d'être
présents dans là rue de converger
justement cette sorte de détresse qui et
qui est présente
est-ce que ça va ça sert à quelque chose
au final oui ça sert à quelque chose
parce qu'il a un volume d'augmentation
de la prise de conscience générale c'est
à dire que tout le monde se sont menacés
aujourd'hui et c'est pour ça que le
mouvement va à mon avis s'inscriront
pour plus dans la durée déjà il
exceptionnel
historiquement mais il va s'inscrire et
s'amplifier encore plus parce que tout
le monde se sont menacés avec cette
violence libéral avec cette concurrence
qui a augmenté le gouvernement est
aujourd'hui parce que le système libéral
on connaît n'est pas d'aujourd'hui mais
il ya toujours eu des corrections et a
toujours eu des dd je dirai où les
gouvernements en fait face à la lutte et
au combat ils achètent
celui-ci non et donc c'est pour ça que
la mobilisation va continuer avec
notamment les étudiants faut pas oublier
la précarisation des étudiants donc
c'est vraiment une convergence
intergénérationnel et une mobilisation
collective qui fait que et bien
gouvernement a encore du pain sur la
planche parce que il a déclaré la guerre
aux gens aux travailleurs ou aux gens de
toutes catégories modestes
c'est ça et c'est une guerre sociale et
je crois qu'elle va avoir des effets
encore plus important dans la
convergence et la lutte mais en tout cas
merci d'avoir été sur d'autres plateaux
je rappelle que vous êtes président de
l'association les oranges